qué tan bien te conoces
esta mejor pudieras con suerte
como puedas conocerte mejor
y pensamos en la forma
más natural de crecer
no tenemos más que voltear nuestro
alrededor
nuestro crecimiento personal
profesional emocional
depende en gran medida de cómo somos
capaces de asimilar
el feedback que recibimos ese feedback
se conoce como esa retroalimentación
cuando tenemos un trabajo o cuando
hacemos algún tipo de manifestación
artística o le damos una charla y esa
retroalimentación nos permite ver y
conocernos de una forma en la que
evidentemente no nos conocemos
ahora la realidad es que este feedback o
esta retroalimentación así como te hace
se puede deshacer
la pregunta es entonces cómo asimilamos
nosotros ese feedback o esa
retroalimentación
puedes pensar cuándo fue la última vez
que tú recibiste un feedback negativo
porque tu institución recibió feedback
negativo
para ejemplificar esto me gustaría
contarles la historia de lo bueno
el güero cuando estaba en la secundaria
las tardes iba al conservatorio nacional
de la música porque tenía la ilusión de
convertirse en un pianista
en el conservatorio tomaba la clase de
solfeo y el solfeo es un entrenamiento
que te permite entender las notas en el
mundo
y la forma en la que se enseña es un
poco como cuando la primaria nos
enseñaron a leer
había un alumno que empezaba a leer y
cuando se equivocaba la maestra lo
corregía y pasaba el siguiente alumno
nos recuerdan de sí
aquí en la diferencia que en la
partitura y estás leyendo a notas
musicales
el maestro golpeaba el escritorio
marcando el tiempo
el alumno decía las notas se equivocaba
y continuaba el siguiente alumno
esto le provocaba al güero una brutal
ansiedad
de tal forma que cuando le tocaba él no
pasaba ni siquiera dos compases
musicales cuando ya se equivoca
y esto irremediablemente le valía a todo
tipo de insultos y humillaciones de
parte del profesor usted
es tan limitado intelectualmente que no
será capaz ni siquiera para vender
chicles afuera de la estación del metro
esta humillación continua durante el
semestre y de repente
fortuitamente estalla la huelga en el
conservatorio en sala de la música
por tanto
el pueblo dijo que suerte no tengo que
enfrentarme a este tenido profesor
hubo un pase automático
y se encontró finalmente en el siguiente
año escolar
sin embargo el daño estaba hecho
y bueno se replanteó y dijo
creo que esto no es para mí
fue así como evidentemente decidió
abandonar el sueño de ser músico
pero para aquellos de ustedes que tienen
un poco de intuición se podrán imaginar
que ese vuelo soy yo
y puse la secundaria la preparatoria y
finalmente decidí estudiar la carrera de
odontología
y llevo ya 30 años dedicado no sólo a la
odontología sino que también a el mundo
la educación el mundo de la enseñanza y
esto me ha permitido explorar una serie
de lugares pero también explorar mi
propia mente
a grado que hoy día
si realmente un poco mejor
y fue cuando decidí buscar ayuda
profesional
y cuando hablé con la terapeuta de mi
vida y de mis experiencias decidí
contarle mi experiencia en el
conservatorio y claro le dije es que a
mí me salvó la huelga
ya me dijo verla
de verdad crees que te salvó la huelga
si la buena lo que hizo es quitarte la
oportunidad de demostrarle a ese
profesor pero sobre todo
de mostrar tepic
tú podías
ese día volvió a cambiar mi vida y me di
cuenta que estamos expuestos 24/7 365
días del año a feedback
y mucho de este no es positivo el mundo
se encarga de decirte verbalmente se
encarga de decirte por escrito qué es lo
que no haces también
se encarga de hacerlo personalmente se
encarga de hacerlo por redes sociales
todos estamos expuestos a recibir este
tipo
bien pues llegó el día en el que vivía
cambio a profesionalmente porque me
invitaron a participar como profesor en
la que quizá es la plataforma de
educación continua en odontología más
importante del mundo
spears education o sistema de educación
continua en odontología fundada
precisamente por el doctor frank spirit
que fue uno de mis profesores cuando
puse la maestría de universia de guardia
esta empresa una empresa de lo más
robusto de hay 300 personas trabajando
en ella se toman las cosas su
prevalencia
bill gates dice nuestra fuente más
grande del conocimiento llega a partir
de nuestros clientes insatisfechos
entonces hay que entender al cliente
insatisfecho para esto siendo una
empresa dedicada a la educación
cada vez que yo me paro a hablar en
público si existe una hoja de evaluación
donde la gente califica es exactamente
lo que le gustó pero sobre todo lo que
no leemos
320 personas calificando mi trabajo en
un altero de páginas le puedo leer
perfectamente qué es lo que piensan
limitada y desde luego vemos lo bueno o
vemos lo malo está lo que vemos lo malo
y afortunadamente lo malo es un muy bajo
porcentaje pero es suficiente suficiente
para conseguir esa sensación de
desorientación y de cine williams one
como una especie de anarquía psicológica
donde nuestra propia existencia se
siente amenazada
y cada vez que leí hay un feedback
negativo me ocurría este es el pseudo
desorientación de tal forma que me
obligó a estudiar el comportamiento
humano
entender por qué respondemos cómo es
y cómo poder cambiar nuestra respuesta
porque el tipo negativo no va a
desaparecer
entonces voy a la tarea de leer una
serie de libros de artículos científicos
entender potencialmente qué pasaba en mi
cabeza
y entender un poco esta ingeniería
conductual y entender mejor esta
respuesta que tiene uno al recibir el
feedback negativo que otra vez el autor
daniel goldman que fue él quien escribió
el libro de inteligencia emocional lo
define como un secuestro amígdala no
existen todo tipo de reacciones
sistémicas cuando recibimos pitar
negativo no sudan las manos se lleva la
frecuencia cardíaca se dilatan las
pupilas
esto de alguna manera hace que nuestro
cerebro reptiliano actúe de modo tal que
hay un efecto que se llama o luchar o
pelear o escapar eso es lo que nuestro
cuerpo hace el cuerpo se prepara cuando
lee ese ataque es esa afrenta o ese
feedback negativo
hardwicke profesora de stanford
university también experta en psicología
conductual escribe este libro de
investigación con respecto a la mente
humana y se da cuenta que hay dos tipos
fundamentalmente de personas aquellos
que tienen una mente una mentalidad fija
aquellos que tiene una mentalidad de
crecimiento
mentalidad fija quiere decir amos dueño
estamos llenos de ideas preconcebidas
las cosas nos pasan por esto
siempre a mí claro y está atacando por
esto y por el tipo
de áfrica quiere decir nuevo al fracaso
hacer las cosas bien pero tener mucho
miedo a fracasar
otro lado tenemos la mentalidad de
crecimiento
aquellos individuos que evolucionan
porque el reto les parece que alimenta
su espíritu
y no se sienten amenazados por el
fracaso sino que ven siempre el espacio
de mejora y la pregunta importante es
podemos transitar de tener una
mentalidad fija a una mentalidad de
crecimiento y la respuesta es claro que
podemos
yo pude y por eso estoy aquí y vengo a
explicarles que esto es relativamente
sencillo pero el concepto que mejor la
ejemplifica es el ejemplo del ejercicio
físico el ejemplo del gimnasio el
ejemplo de la disciplina todos sabemos
que cuando vamos a ir al gimnasio si o
si nuestro cuerpo va a decir ay me
siento incómodo
sin embargo lo seguimos haciendo
hasta que lo empezamos sentir
cómodamente incómodos
y esa es la consigna
de la misma forma en la que aprendemos a
sentirnos cómodamente incómodos cuando
vamos al gimnasio eso es precisamente la
propuesta del día de hoy
a la hora de enfrentarnos a la vida no
solo al gimnasio
buena fácil y lo que les voy a ir ahora
también suena fácil
pero no es tan fácil porque se trata de
soltar dos elementos que viven adentro
de nosotros en menor o en mayor forma
pero evidentemente es el miedo
y el segundo es la culpa y es la
combinación entre miedo y culpa la que
nos hace vivir esa personalidad fija
entonces la consigna es despojarnos
precisamente de este miedo para
enfrentarnos sabiendo que estaremos
cómodamente incómodos y que
encontraremos la forma de salir adelante
y de evolucionar
me gustaría compartir con ustedes un
ejemplo muy a propósito de este formato
esta fue una plática como ésta edex en
la que participé hace cinco años y es la
práctica en una plática que ha tenido
múltiples reproducciones y al final de
reproducciones hay también más de 100
comentarios ya me conoce cuáles son los
comentarios que leo con más interés
quería compartir con ustedes tres de
esos comentarios que evidentemente
seleccioné para este el día del primer
comentario
puras pendejadas
ahora hasta un carnicero es
conferencista jajaja
segundo comentario que llueva de
conferencia el tipo no tiene ni ritmo ni
coherencia lamentable
tercer comentario muy buena potencia
pero hay demasiado movimiento hacia
momento corporal cansa la vista
si revisamos parte del trabajo de taller
que escribe este magnífico libro se
llama insight nos habla de la manera en
la que sistemáticamente tendríamos que
ser capaces nosotros de enfrentarlos al
tipo negativo y parte de lo que yo dice
es número uno no nos apresuremos en
reaccionar
trata de obtuviera toda la información
que puedas
no te conviertas en un mártir solitario
ay esto me pasa a mí
y recuerda que el cambio es
absolutamente funcional
a partir de estos cuatro puntos
analicemos entonces el feedback que
recibimos y busquemos cuáles son las
palabras claves
puras pendejadas no tiene ritmo ni
coherencia claramente es demasiado
momento corporal
al hacer la disección de estas tres
críticas que parecerían que son muy
hostiles aún aquí soy capaz de ver y
somos capaces de ver el espacio de
mejora
el espacio de mejora que vive al hacer
la reflexión por tanto la conclusión en
la que llegamos es uno
vigila tu ritmo y tu coherencia
procura no moverte tanto cansa tu
movimiento corporal y 3 trata no decir
tanta pendejada
por un segundo quiero que piensen que si
no hay feedback negativo y que si todo
el feedback que recibimos es positivo
dónde queda el espacio de crecimiento
piensen en lo limitante
sería la vida
piensen en la gran mentira que
viviríamos
la consigna otra vez es apretar el botón
en las mañanas y decir hoy estoy
dispuesta a sentirme cómodamente
incómodo
y te pregunto tú conoces a alguien a tu
alrededor a quien te gustaría invitarlo
a que se sientan cómodamente y cómodo
que sea capaz de retar aprender del
titán negativo
quizá algún miembro de su familia
quizás algún compañero de trabajo
quizá algún funcionario
es a lo mejor algún presidente
de espacio de mejora del crecimiento
y llegar a un conocimiento mayor
vive a partir de sentirnos cómodamente
y como nos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]